hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
at a number of points in his passes
Blaze Pascal is going to criticize the
stoics for in his view making some
fundamental mistakes he's not singling
them out as the only people that are off
he's going to talk about plenty of other
philosophical positions philosophies as
ways of life that in his View kind of
gets something right and then gets more
things wrong and you're going to notice
that he will talk about Epictetus the
great late or Roman stoic who is being
widely read at that time he's also got
in mind contemporary people of his own
time who identify as neostoics or who
are influenced by stoicism in one way or
another and I think that a really good
place for understanding the nature of
his criticism which is quite
sophisticated is actually in the very
short section 394.
he tells us all the principles of now
notice he's going to talk about not just
stoics
Skeptics
stoics atheists
Etc so he's including more possible all
their principles are true
so is he endorsing a kind of everybody's
got things right no he's saying that
their principles are true but
they're making a fundamental mistake
which leads to their conclusions being
false so they're over all here's how you
ought to live here's my advice to you
why because the opposite principles are
also true so each of these represents a
particular way of getting something
right
and globalizing that universalizing that
saying this is the only part that
matters and then thereby not paying
attention to the opposite principles not
giving them their due not incorporating
them and this leads to getting things
fundamentally wrong in section
434 and 4 35
there's some fleshing out of this so he
tells us
um that there's there's two uh truths of
Faith equally certain the one that human
beings in the state of creation or that
of Grace is raised above all Nature Made
like unto God and sharing in his
divinity the other that in the state of
corruption and sin he's fallen from this
state and made like onto the Beast and
then he says these two propositions are
equally sound and certain and he you
know talks about how you could learn
this through looking at scripture now do
you have to have a Christianity informed
religious Viewpoint to grasp either of
these principles he says no and so in
435 he goes out and he says without this
Divine knowledge what could people do
but either become elated by the inner
feeling of their past greatness which
Still Remains to them or become
despondent at the site of their present
weakness so you know the the human being
is excellent and corrupt so not seeing
the whole truth he says they could not
attain to perfect virtue right they they
can't have it all they can have some of
it but not all of it and it goes on he
says some considering nature as
incorrupt others as incurable they could
not escape and NOW essential interesting
that he's going to frame Vice in terms
of two main uh you could call them
deadly vices uh Capital devices the ones
that lead to the others and one is not a
surprise Pride right in Christian
thought this has been a big problem you
know it's viewed as like one of The
Fountains of of sin right but the other
one that he talks about is sloth or
laziness Peres in in French so he goes
on and he says
um they could not Escape either Pride or
sloth the two sources of all Vice why
they cannot but abandon themselves to it
through cowardice or Escape it by Pride
if they knew the Excellence of human
beings they were ignorant of their
corruption so that allows them to avoid
sloth but they easily fall into Pride
if they recognize the infirmity of
nature they were ignorant of its dignity
so that they could easily avoid vanity
but it was to fall into despair so
you've got two choices right you can
either
focus on the infirmity the corruption of
human beings and then you're going to be
slothful you're going to focus on
infirmity and fall into despair disease
right or you ignore that and you focus
on the Excellence of human beings which
is you know a true Excellence then you
are driven by pride and that leads to
vanity so
these are the two choices and then what
does these say after that
thus arise the different schools of the
stoics and epicureans the dogmatists
academicians ETC so the stoics are
definitely on one side of this Choice
which side are they selecting well you
know we see this in section
350. this is the fundamental mistake
that he thinks that they make the stoics
it's actually titled that this paragraph
they conclude that what has been done
once you know at one point in time can
be done always and that sense the desire
of Glory imparts some power to Those
whom it possesses others can do likewise
and he has a very interesting analogy
here he says there are feverish
movements which health cannot imitate
so he's actually going to indust you
know the next couple paragraphs he'll
say the strength of a person's virtue
must not be measured by their efforts
but their ordinary life what it is that
they're capable of consistently day to
day and so the stoics they look at human
beings and they're like wow you know
that person is able to you know not fear
death therefore that's possible for all
of us you know Socrates is a prime
example in epictetus's writings who uh
Pascal is going to bring up immediately
right he says in 350
Epictetus concludes that since there are
consistent Christians every man can
easily be so now obviously Epictetus
doesn't think that he's not paying
attention to Christianity he does
mention you know uh Jewish people at one
point in the discourses but he's not
really engaged with the religion of
Christianity but the implication would
be hey if this person say a saint or you
know a martyr or somebody who's doing
something really extraordinary if they
could live in the desert for you know 25
years constantly praying well everybody
can do that the stoics aren't doing that
so much with you know prayer or matters
that are more germane to Christianity
but they're doing that with a lot of
other stuff saying hey if he can do it
or she can do it then I can do it and
you can do it and we all can do it we're
all capable of it and that's true in the
abstract right but there's too much
emphasis on the fact that we can do that
and not enough
um on what holds us back what what
interferes with us the corruption of
human nature in 360 he'll follow this up
by saying what the stoics propose is so
difficult
and interestingly choice of words here
foolish lacking in wisdom now wisdom is
for the stoics the you know virtue par
Excellence right and he says he follows
this up by saying something that's quite
true of the stoic School the stoics lay
down that all those who are not at the
high degree of wisdom are equally
foolish and vicious
as those who are two inches under water
now what's the reference there so the
stoics when they were talking about
virtue and and wisdom they would say
listen it's like an on off switch you're
either on this side and you're wise or
you're on this side and you're foolish
even if you're making progress you're
making progress as a foolish person you
haven't crossed the threshold into
wisdom and it's like drowning you know
you can be not drowning or drowning and
you can drown just as easily in two
inches of water if that's going into
your lungs as you can if you're in the
whole ocean right so you could be very
very foolish and vicious over here
that's the whole ocean you could be in
two inches of water but you haven't
lifted your face up from it and you you
die as a result so you know again Pascal
is saying you stoics you wind up being
too extreme because you're not paying
enough attention to you know this
totality of human beings
a little bit later on in 465 and 467
he's going to uh
talk about some traditional stoic let's
call them dogmas or sayings or things
that you should keep in mind and so the
first one in 465 he says the stoic say
retire within yourselves it is there you
will find your rest this is probably
familiar to anybody who's ever heard the
phrase the inner Citadel right coming
from Marcus Aurelius Seneca Epictetus
say similar things you if you just
withdraw into the realm of what you
actually have control over what you can
be conscious of nobody can beat you
and then Pascal says well this is not
true
others by contrast say go out of
yourself seek happiness and amusement
like the epicureans and this is not true
either
happiness Pascal says is neither without
us nor within us it's in God both
without us and within us so once again
he's criticizing the stoics for getting
you know emphasizing one side of the
equation and missing out on the other
when it comes to The Human Condition
he also talks about epictetuses
um you know distinction which is
rather let's say the emphasis on it is
unique to Epictetus
um
the distinction between what is in our
power or what is not in our power and
Pascal says he did not perceive that
it's not on our power to regulate the
heart and it was wrong to infer this
from the fact that there were some
Christians once again you know Epictetus
isn't really engaging with Christians
but uh if he were able to if he was in
the you know early modern period and
talking with neostoics Epictetus would
be saying yeah man you you can all do it
it's all within your realm of control
and Pascal is saying well no the heart
is more complicated than just the
thinking or willing that we you know
happen to do and we don't always control
precisely what the heart
wants what it doesn't want you know and
now is this Fair criticism could the
stoics respond to him at all I think a
case could be made that stoics could you
know make some response to this but you
know Epictetus is actually laying out a
very interesting position he's not
saying those stoics are completely wrong
they began for mistaken assumptions
about human nature he's saying they
didn't begin from enough
assumptions or principles about the
human condition and therefore they wound
up at erroneous conclusions just like
all the other philosophical sects and
pretty much all the other religions out
there except for according to Pascal
Christianity so these are his criticisms
of the stoic school and the neostoics of
his time